let's talk about trade Donald Trump has
started yet another trade war this one
with our ally Canada yeah Trump is
hitting one of our biggest allies Canada
with steel and aluminum tariffs he's
also hitting Mexico as well as the
European Union there had been a
two-month exemption for them that
exemption is being eliminated the
initial announcement came from Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross he said that they
were doing it didn't really say much
about why nor what Canada Mexico and the
EU can or should do to have these
terrorists removed and the EU
immediately announced counter tariffs
Canada immediately announced can't
counter tariffs as well as a total
condemnation of the policy and here's
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
making the announcement today we find
ourselves the target of punitive tariffs
on Canadian aluminum and steel under
pretext of a 2/3 to national security
provision let me be clear these tariffs
are totally unacceptable for 150 years
Canada has been the United States's most
steadfast ally the numbers are clear the
United States has a two billion US
dollar surplus in steel trade with
Canada and Canada buys more American
steel than any other country in the
world
indeed we account for half of US exports
u.s. steel exports Canada is a secure
supplier of aluminum and steel to the US
defense industry putting aluminum in
American planes and steel in American
tanks that Canada could be considered a
national security threat to the United
States is inconceivable these tariffs
are an affront to the long-standing
security partnership between Canada and
the United States and in particular and
affront to the thousands of Canadians
who have fought and died alongside their
American brothers in arms'
I want to be very clear about one thing
Americans remain our partners our allies
and our friends this is not about the
American people we have to believe that
at some point common sense will prevail
yeah I wouldn't be so sure about common
sense prevailing when Trump is still in
the White House remember when we had a
leader that could speak coherently and
eloquently it wasn't that long ago right
but it does it's still jarring when you
see Justin Trudeau compared to Trump
well at least we can still be friends
that's a good thing I guess that's what
he's saying with the people anyway
Canada has immediately announced they
are putting dollar-for-dollar tariffs on
American steel aluminum whiskey orange
juice other food products and other
products in total the dollar amounts
will be the same again these are dollar
for dollar tariffs and this is already
hurting American business their
architectural firms reporting that the
price of domestic aluminum plates has
gone way up this is something they are
experiencing as a result of the China
tariffs now it's going to get even worse
Trump says he's all about the real
estate industry the construction
industry this hurts those industries
directly I have a friend in the concrete
business who's being hurt by the tariffs
says it's going to get even worse
because of this because of what are
called the costs of complementary goods
like when you put a tariff on steel and
aluminum and the cost of construction
goes up and people do less of it
complementary businesses like concrete
for pouring foundations for examples
start to get hurt not all of this is
from the tariffs themselves because not
every element of these tariffs have been
enacted but what starts to happen is
when the tariffs are announced
businesses will start pre buying some of
the materials that will become more
expensive and that drives the prices up
and it's not just Canada responding
Mexico has also responded according to
the Associated Press Mexico answers US
tariffs with its own on products in true
including pork bellies grapes apples and
flat steel just you wait until avocados
from Mexico cost six bucks each the
hipsters will rage and this trade war
stuff has become basically a
geopolitical penis size contest Trump
doesn't understand trade this is not
going to be good for the American people
or for American
this period it will be bad for jobs it
will make things more expensive for
Americans and George W Bush tried some
of this nonsense lost a bunch of jobs
then ended up kind of backing off of it
and Trump may not have the same sense or
common sense or shame I guess that Bush
ultimately decided to consider a when
backing off but this is a government
that is sort of government by ADHD or
government by Fox and Friends or
government by incompetence or some
combination right I don't know exactly
what to call it the summit with Kim
jong-un is on then it's off then it's
back on tariffs are on but Canada is
exempted but we're cancelling the
exemption so we actually are going to
tariffs Canada there's this dilute
excuse me this delusional element of
getting choked up because this is so
insane there's a delusional element to
Trump's policy that is incredibly
dangerous and is if there was ever a
case for using the 25th amendment for
the removal of a president it's this
continued erratic nature of bad policy
enacted on a whim and eliminated just as
quickly which has made the United States
once again a laughingstock around the
world and the trade war cannot be won
Trump can't win this okay this doesn't
mean that I don't recognize some of the
destructive elements of so-called free
trade policies over the last thirty
years given where we started at the
beginning of Trump's presidency getting
in a trade war with Canada is not
something that's going to be good for us
or our economy or the American people
it's absolutely pathetic and
embarrassing